rené rousset à son nom gravé à l'entrée
du lycée jules haag comme plus de 70
anciens élèves
il n'a pas eu le temps de vieillir
résistant il a été fusillé à besançon
par la gestapo en septembre 1943 il
avait 26 ans
quelques jours auparavant il a écrit une
dernière lettre à son amoureuse la
petite a lâché je viens d'envoyer un
dernier adieu
un dernier baiser dans quelques instants
je passerai devant le peloton
d'exécution je suis pour à vue je crois
lettres console un peu et en montre leur
ont sacrifice n'a pas été vain
je t'aime de toutes mes forces je
revenais pas de l'émotion qui avait dans
cette lettre j'ai eu les larmes aux yeux
même en la relisant encore le ce matin
quand j'ai entendu à cette année j'avais
encore les larmes aux yeux et je les
fais lire à mawazine qui est à côté de
moi et je lui dis mais c'est incroyable
ces mots ils sont tellement forts que ça
donne envie de pleurer avec sa classe de
terminale andréanne a cherché à retracer
la courte vie de rené rousset et de tous
et non inscrit à l'entrée de leur lycée
un devoir de mémoire au toc une ligne de
vie c'est inspirant comme engagement
aujourd'hui on vit dans un en temps de
paix donc on n'irait pas jusqu'à se
sacrifier ça c'est une autre vie
peut-être mais dans tous les jours on
trouve toujours un moyen de s'engager
s'engager départ des petites actions au
quotidien et ce qui fait que on oeuvre
pour une société meilleure peut-être une
fleur pour un nom pour une histoire à
faire vivre et qui pour certaines
restent encore à écrire sur le tout
nouveau site internet du lycée il ya des
jambes c'est rien que le nom le prénom
et rien d'autre bon c'est pas leur date
de naissance on sait pas comment ils
sont morts il ya des erreurs il y en a
qui sont marqués alors qu'il n'était pas
mort et à peut-être des gens qui sont
morts et qui sont pas marqué donc voilà
c'est toute cette histoire qu'on
aimerait refaire donc encore des gens
qui peuvent avoir de souvenir de cette
histoire georges rover rené rousset sans
nom prononcé à haute voix sans
combattants fusillait la citadelle de
besançon
parmi eux deux anciens élèves du lycée
andré hahn et tous ceux qui ont
travaillé sur le site internet ne les
ouvre
on parle voorhees chaudet